Okay,
so you know how I been telling you guys
about the hierarchical model,
you know where the motor actions on the
bottom and then higher order abstract
conceptions at the top so you can be a
good person if you're a good parent,
you don't know how to take care of your
children.
If you can keep your house orderly and
productivity.
If you can make dinner,
if you can set a table and so on,
all the way decomposed all the way down
to motor actions,
right?
So it brings you from the level of
abstract to the level of concrete.
Okay,
so now think about this,
so keep that in your mind first.
Now the second thing you want to keep in
your mind is the kind of models that we
were talking about a little bit last
week.
So they're the,
their expectancy models that were
derived from vinegar,
Nova and soca law and so forth and,
and,
and really,
you know,
finalized in some sense by great.
Now,
what those models say fundamentally is
that if you're moving towards a target,
a conservatory target,
which would be specified by hypothalamic
or other underlying motivational systems
or some combination of those,
sometimes it can be a higher order goal.
Then anything that occurs while you're
proceeding towards that goal,
that indicates that you're going to get
it or move closer to it,
produces positive emotion.
Okay?
And that's mediated by the hypothalamic
exploratory,
paused,
have an effect circuit that runs through
the nucleus accumbens,
and it basically runs on dopamine.
Okay?
So that's positive emotion.
Roughly speaking,
it's positive emotion in relationship to
incentive reward.
What happens if you attain the goal,
which is the consumer story.
Reward is it satisfies you,
and that's also a form of reward,
but it's not associated with as much
positive emotion,
it's more associated with
the lack of necessity to do that
anymore,
you know,
so you're done with that and that can be
satisfying and it does seem to be
motivated mediated by Serotonin,
which is basically a satiating agent
among its other properties.
Okay?
So that's on the positive emotion end of
things.
Um,
briefly,
an incentive reward is also equivalent
to a conditioned reward in classical
behavior theory,
so that's actually something you should
probably know,
but all talk about it a bit more because
you kind of need,
you need to know how behavior is theory
developed across time because behaviors,
theory has been incredibly instill is
incredibly influential in neuroscience,
especially in the real neuroscience,
which is almost always done with
animals.
So,
so that's one of the positive emotion
in.
Now let's go to the negative emotion.
And so now you're proceeding towards a
goal and something gets in your way.
Um,
you're walking across the carpet to go
to work and you step on a dog bone,
you know,
and that's maybe a little painful,
but we'll keep that apart from this
discussion for a moment.
It constitutes an impediment to your
progress forward,
or maybe your kid left,
uh,
you know,
like a piece of furniture in the
hallway,
that's a better example.
So it's a bit of an obstacle and when
you look at that,
then that's going to produce negative
emotion.
And the negative emotion is because
there's an obstacle in your path.
Now you might say,
how much negative emotion should you
experienced when you encounter an
obstacle?
And that's something that I don't
remember if I got,
if I assigned you guys the entropy paper
that I wrote with Jacob Hersch and
Raymond Martin,
but anyways,
we,
we took a long time to figure out how
you might calibrate how upset you should
get when something negative happens.
And what we realized fundamentally was
that it was proportional to the place in
the hierarchy where your goals were
disrupted.
You know,
so if you just have to make a minor
course correction by walking around,
the amount of upset you should get is
basically proportional to the amount of
extra energy that you have to expand
correcting your course.
And so a minor obstacle is just going
to,
you know,
produce a little bit of arousal and
stress.
Whereas if you go out to try to start
your car and it won't start well,
then that's gonna make you more upset,
experience more negative emotion.
You know?
And if,
if you read that you're,
the business you work in has just
collapsed because of the CEO was a
crook.
And now it's bankrupt,
that's going to cause you even more
distressed.
And the distress,
roughly speaking,
should be proportional to the level of
the hierarchy in your expectancy network
or desire network more accurately.
That's disrupted by the occurrence.
Okay?
So in that,
that makes sense.
It's solid.
And then,
um,
you know,
then there's the special case of things
you don't know about,
you know,
so,
and,
and often when something gets in your
way,
the problem with what gets in your way
is you actually can't compute how much
time and energy it's going to take you
to fix it.
And so it's very hard to calibrate how
much negative emotion you're going to
feel under those circumstances,
right?
Like the,
for example,
how anxious should you get if your car
quits working while they answered that
is you don't know.
And because maybe it'll never work
again,
you know,
and then it would depend on,
well,
you know,
do you have enough money to replace it?
And how much trouble will you run into
practically speaking,
if you use that money to replace it.
And then it might also depend on,
um,
your baseline levels of neuroticism
because what a neuroticism neuroticism
is,
it's the negative emotion factor in the
big five.
What neuroticism is,
is a,
it's a,
it's a role of the genetic dice which
says that your body should output x
amount of physiological energy or
preparation for energy in response to x
amount of disruption.
And X varies,
right?
So imagine that.
Imagine you're calibrated for a
dangerous environment.
So on average,
the evolutionary design dice has
designed your genetic system so that
you're much more reactive to a normal
list or punishing things,
anomalous or threatening things more
accurately punishing as well than the
typical person might be.
Now,
you might say,
well,
is that right?
Is that wrong?
Is there something wrong with that?
It's like there's nothing wrong with
that at all.
If it turns out that on average,
the environment tends to be much more
dangerous than the typical human
environment.
You know,
now it might be kind of rough on you,
especially if you have a nervous system
that's high in neuroticism when you're
actually not at that much risk,
roughly speaking.
Then there'd be a mismatch between the
genetic roll of the dice and the average
safety of the environment.
And you know,
modern environments are pretty safe.
So we all worry about being anxious,
which is funny because we're anxious
about being anxious and the reason we
can afford to be anxious about being
anxious is because we actually don't
experience that many punishments
compared to what we might have
experienced 120 years ago.
You know,
when the average daily income incorrect
to dollars for people in North America
was under a dollar a day,
you know,
that was hard.
So okay,
so anyways,
your neuroticism is one of the things
that that helps determine how much upset
you should experience per unit of
uncertainty or threat.
Okay.
Another thing is your status among other
people.
So you might think,
well,
what else should determine how anxious
you get when something you don't want
happens?
And you might say,
well,
your competence and your competence,
roughly speaking should be how good on
average are you compared to other people
at dealing with problems when they
arise.
And so competence is actually one of the
more,
um,
what would you say?
Cognitive elements of what you might
call self esteem,
you know,
if it turns out that you're pretty good
at problem solving or it turns out that
you actually have a very wide network of
social resources,
which basically boils down to the same
thing,
right?
It doesn't really matter if you can
solve a problem,
if you know someone who can solve the
problem.
So social network and intrinsic
computational resources are comparable
phenomena.
And if you turn out to be a good problem
solver,
then on average you should be less upset
when something is upsetting than someone
who isn't a good problem solver.
Okay?
So that makes sense.
I presumed now here's something I've
been thinking for a long time and
there's a lot of debate about this and
the relevant literature.
The terror management people,
for example,
they claim that people get anxious
because they're afraid of death.
Um,
you know,
at a psychological level,
it's lurking at the back of their minds
all the time.
It's an existential problem and I
suppose that's because death is one of
those threats that threatens you right
at the very top of your hierarchy,
right?
Good person and dead person don't go
well together.
So death threatens the entire hierarchy.
And so it's very anxiety provoking.
That seems quite reasonable as a
proposition.
Now the other thing that happens in the
terror management theorists,
theories which are,
which are variants of the Freud Freud in
theories,
is that there's a further
claim made,
which is that
belief systems protect you against death
anxiety.
Now this is a complicated claim.
Partly it,
it,
it is extracted from Freud's observation
that religious systems are protective
against death anxiety.
He actually thought they were neurotic
protections against dense,
that they have anxiety.
So it was sort of like,
like a primitive faith in the ability of
the father roughly speaking to solve the
problem and protect you.
So he thought it was a projection of the
infant tile world onto the broader world
and powerful critique.
I think sometimes it's true and the
death anxiety people,
the terror management people who
basically developed their theories from
a book by
the book's called the denial of death.
I'll remember the author in a moment
anyways.
It doesn't matter.
The theory was broadened out to to
propose that your belief systems as
such,
I provided you with that protection and
then there was a bit of a variation of
that theory,
which was your vision of yourself as an
illusory climber upon value hierarchy
also protected you now exactly how it
protected you.
It was never really explained,
and I'm not taking issue with Becker.
Ernest Becker,
Becker,
who wrote the book.
Becker is a smart guy.
It's a great book.
It's dangerously wrong,
but it's.
But it's a great book.
Well,
lots of great books.
You know,
they,
they're,
they're wrong and an extraordinarily
interesting way and that makes them.
That can make them a great book.
I think Becker's wrong because he
assumes that are all everything we do to
cope with death.
Anxiety is actually an illusion and I
think that's a terrible thing.
Terrible idea.
It's extraordinarily dangerous idea and
I also don't believe it's true for
reasons I'll talk to you about later
anyways,
you can sort of see that,
so then we can lay that on top of the
expectations theory in some sense,
right?
Because basically what the expectancy
theory people do do like gray is they
assume,
okay,
novelty itself is both threatening and
incentive rewarding.
So it's threatening because God only
knows what might happen to you if you
run into something novel and it's.
It has an incentive reward element
because if you dig around in the
novelty,
you never know what sort of treasure you
might bring to the surface and so people
have an ambivalent relationship with
novelty and I think you can actually
understand how that ambivalent
relationship works.
If you think about the hierarchy again,
so here's the,
here's the rough proposition.
If an enormously emerges at the lowest
level,
the highest resolution level,
then it's sort of interesting.
You know,
so a baby might be playing with a fork
and you know,
find out that the forte makes a tinging
noise when he hits it on the table.
Now that doesn't terrify the baby.
It's funny though,
you know when you see babies on youtube
now go absolutely pick it,
absolutely terrified if their mothers
sneezes or sometimes if she laughs,
you know,
so anyways,
but whatever for if the baby's sort of
mastered a fork,
then the fact that it makes a ticking
noise is gonna make them curious and
that's an incentive reward phenomena
more than frightened,
you know,
it's going to depend to some degree on
the baby's level of neuroticism.
And it might also depend on how close
the baby is to the mother because it
actually turns out that maternal
proximity proximity more dilates the
expression of negative emotion and
children and touch really does that by
the way,
which is quite cool.
And that's that strict site that's
direct physical physiology touches
calming and it's also analgesic,
which is quite cool.
So it quells pain.
So okay,
so anyways,
the baby is making this ticking noise
and he finds that quite interesting
because it never happened before.
And so he's curious enough about it to
replicate it,
to do it again and he's under the
control of his psychomotor approach
systems.
And they mediate exploration as well,
positive promotion,
but
you know,
it's a great big dog comes bounding in,
well the dog has teeth and it's big and
it,
you know,
maybe it's got a deep bark and all that.
So it's associated with,
with unexpected movement power and
predatory features.
Like you know,
lots of babies,
let's say toddlers will run and hide
behind their mother that's a little bit
more novelty than they can really
tolerate.
And so you might think that whether you
find something positive or negative when
it's a normal plus,
depends on how high up in the hierarchy
the threat apparently exists.
Okay?
Now here's another corollary.
Let's assume that before you build your
map of the world,
which you could think about as a map of
expectancy or you think about as a map
of desire or of how to fulfill desire.
Or You could think about it as a map of
how to organize your body and your
thoughts in the world so that when you
express that in the world,
the world delivers you what it wants.
And I think that's the most accurate
terminology.
Okay.
The,
the,
the idea there is that as you build up
and differentiate this map,
you bring the,
uh,
normally under control because you
reduce it from God only knows what it is
to something you can either use or
ignore and that regulates your nervous
system chronically.
So the a priori phenomena is novelty and
that would be equivalent to the
phenomenologists thing that shines
forth.
Same idea,
completely different derivation,
and then you build a model that inhibits
it,
and the rule is the mortal inhibits it
as if when you act out the model,
it delivers what you want it to deliver,
which is kind of a form of pragmatism
from a philosophical perspective.
So you understand that.
So then the next proposition is that
model inhibits anxiety.
Okay?
Now you can see that that idea is akin
to the idea that your culture inhibits
death anxiety.
Although I would say it's a more
delineated model and it explains,
it better be part of the problem with a
death anxiety idea is that first of all,
your culture is not in your head.
Right?
Where's your culture
and your beliefs there?
It's around you.
Yeah,
yeah,
so a big part of the culture,
the culture is the fact that you're all
sitting there,
you know,
basically clones of each other doing
exactly the same thing in this room at
exactly the same time.
That's the damn culture and it means
that you can all ignore each other and
concentrate on something else.
And so the culture is all like it's the
floor beneath your feet.
It's the ceiling over your head.
It's the car you drive to work.
It's,
you know,
it's the traffic light system that
pretty much everybody attends to.
So in some sense the matches,
the culture is actually the match
between the technologies and and webs of
comprehension that the individuals use
in the world and the world.
It's the match.
It's not the phenomena itself and it's
certainly not only what you believe in
your head,
which is a little too much on the
psychoanalytic and it doesn't take into
account the pragmatics of culture,
which are the things we act out and the
technological phenomena that exist and
the whole web of game,
like structures.
Those are all embedded in.
So that would be a of an idea,
right?
All this stuff's organized and very much
high order games and as long as it works
the way you think will work in the
world.
So that keeps your anxiety under control
because there's no mismatch,
but even better,
not only are you not afraid of death at
every moment,
but yeah,
actually don't die,
which is even better than not being
afraid of death,
right?
Because you're not freezing to death in
here and there's no insurrection and the
probability that you're going to get run
over on the way home.
It's pretty damn low as long as you
follow the rules.
And so we should never remember that.
Culture is culture is not only
represented in the interior space,
it's not only beliefs,
its actions,
and we should also remember very,
very carefully that it's distributed in
the world.
Okay?
So back to the match mismatch idea.
So you've got this map of how your of
what effects your behaviors are going to
have in the world when you implement
them,
and sometimes that match works,
in which case you're pretty happy
because that's an incentive reward.
You're moving towards your goal and it's
happening.
Not only that,
and this is a secondary thing that the
behaviorists could never get a handle on
because they didn't use hierarchical
representations in this way.
One of the advantages,
I mean,
imagine that you're trying to pick
someone up and it's going pretty well.
Well,
there's two sources of reward there.
One is it's going pretty well.
The second is you're the sort of person
who in this situation can implement a
strategy that's going well,
right?
So not only is it a signal that you're
making progress,
it's a signal that the structure that
you're using to guide your actions and
your perceptions while you're making
progress is working so it validates the
whole damn theory and you know that will
echo through your entire hierarchy of
presupposition.
It's especially true.
I used an amazing scenario because you
know those are particularly relevant to
self esteem,
let's say,
which is a word that no one should ever
be allowed to use,
but will.
It's a word that we'll use in this
situation on the less so and it's hard
to tell exactly what's being reinforced
or reward.
Reward is feeling good.
Reinforcement is how the structures that
you're using to perceive and approach
what you're perceiving and approaching
are asked to grow.
Okay,
so most of the time if,
if something happens that's rewarding,
what that means is the structures that
you have been using to bring about that
outcome are actually cold.
To grow a bit,
gets stronger and Dopa means seems to do
that as well as making you feel good and
sometimes I wonder,
it's not exactly this because you can
separate reward and reinforcement,
but sometimes I wonder if the goodness
of feeling isn't associated with the
thriving and flourishing of neural
tissue.
You know,
it's like it's an invitation to grow
instead of die because if you're being
punished and threatened all the time,
then the systems that are leading you to
be in those situations do get
extinguished.
Fundamentally.
They get starved of what gives them life
and they wither away or are inhibited.
I don't think that's very pleasant.
Okay,
so you got your map and you got the
world and you're acting out this map and
hopefully the match between your map of
the world is such that the Mac matches
the world and if it doesn't,
you get into normally and then the
anomaly can be of different sizes
proportionate to the hierarchy and then
your emotional response is proportionate
to where the anomaly seems to rest in
the hierarchy as well.
Subject to your own neuroticism,
say,
and your own competence,
which we could think of as somewhat
separate phenomena.
Okay.
So then you can say the reason that
people don't like other people who are
foreigners say or different ethnicity or
who have different belief systems is
because they appeared to challenge the
integrity of that map.
And so because their belief systems and
the way they act first of all aren't
very well mapped by the map.
So you don't know what the hell those
people are up to,
you know,
and the differences may be much smaller
than you think.
But what do you know?
You don't know?
Um,
plus if their belief systems come with
them,
which they will,
that has an indeterminant effect on the
structure,
the map,
and it also has an indeterminant effect
on your position within the map.
And so then those theories,
and it's a part of that is the theory
that I developed in the book called maps
of meaning that theory proposes at least
in part that the reason that people
cling to their belief systems the way
they do is because of their belief
systems are disrupted at a high level,
low resolution level.
Just that the,
you know,
level of action or way the hell up the
hierarchy in terms of the definition of
the good or what constitutes a redeemed
person or something like that.
Then that brings out tremendous
disruption and then you'd expect to
phenomena from that.
You'd expect that people would be afraid
say a foreigners are a strange ideas,
but also that they'd be kind of
interested in them.
And I think generally our interactions
with people who aren't like us generally
or we think aren't like us,
whatever take place at a level where
it's more curiosity than fear.
I mean,
that would be almost the definition of a
of a sustainable tolerant society,
right?
Everything around you is functioning
well enough so that if someone comes
along who's different in belief or
action,
they're not gonna.
You're not gonna.
Assume they're there a fatal threat to
the integrity of your hierarchy and fall
apart because of terror and curiosity.
Mostly tear.
Okay,
so now you can vary that theory a bit
and you can say,
wait a minute.
Maybe it's not just anxiety that gets
inhibited when your belief systems are
structured to some degree,
maybe it's more primordial.
Maybe what happens is that it's more
akin to the generalized stress response,
which seems to be a more primordial and
global reaction to threat or anomaly,
and the generalized stress response
basically occurs or seems to occur when
the hippocampus.
So the hippocampus,
the map seems to be associated with the
hippocampus in some way.
Now the hippocampus is also the part of
the brain that takes what you're
observing and transforms Osho show short
term attention and transforms it into
medium to longterm memory.
So first of all,
the hippocampus keeps track of what it
is that you're seeing and then it stores
it there for awhile and then later it
integrates it into the generalized map
and so then the hippocampus seems to
sort of stay at that nexus of the map
which is likely represented cortically
to a large degree and what's actually
going on in the world.
So for example,
grades hypothesis,
roughly speaking is you're watching what
goes on in the world and the map is
telling you what's supposed to happen
and then when something else happens,
the hippocampus detects that that's a
mismatch and then somehow it makes you
afraid.
Now here's how it seems to make you
This I don't think was really laid out
well until vinegar.
Dova discovered it when she was really
old.
I mean she was doing most of her work in
the early sixties,
but she laid this out.
I think it was in the early two
thousands.
What she showed was that,
okay,
so you have this part in the bottom of
your,
of your nervous system way,
the hell down there called the reticular
activating system.
And it's old,
old,
and it's the thing upon which your sleep
wake cycles dependent,
so and your consciousness without your
particular activating system is down.
It's like you're unplugged.
So if you have a car accident way back
here,
if you have a car accident and your head
twists enough to shear off the neural
projections from the reticular
activating system,
you're in a permanent and irreversible
coma.
It was pretty interesting a because it
means your consciousness depends on
something that's not new.
Like you're relatively new,
like your cortical cap,
but something that's so damn old that it
was there before your whole brain.
So that's pretty weird.
Anyways,
what vinegar Dover proposed was that
the hippocampus,
the hippocampus decides that's what's
what's going on.
Roughly matches what you expect or what
you want,
which is more accurate than it tells the
reticular activating system not to be in
a panic.
And then the reticular activating system
controlled.
We're going to assume it's on all the
time,
except when it's told to be off.
The hippocampus says you can more or
less stay off right now because
everything's going according to plan.
And then all of a sudden,
poof,
things don't go according to plan.
The hippocampus tells,
the reticular re releases the reticular
activating system from inhibition and
then the reticular activating system
wakes up all your sub cortical circuits
and that stress and so wake up would
mean get afraid,
but it would also mean prepared to get
the hell out of there.
So prepare to panic and then it might
also mean ready other motivational
systems,
just in case they might be useful.
And then that also means shut off your
immune system because who the hell cares
about that?
If you're being chased by a tiger,
you know and pull all the sugar out of
your blood because you bloody well are
going to need the energy.
And so it's an emergency preparedness
state.
So then you could say that when you
encounter in a normally what happens is
that your body generates an emergency
preparation state and the magnitude of
that is proportional to your perception
of where the threat of what level the
threat corresponds to in your map.
Okay,
got it.
Is that makes sense.
Okay.
So there's something wrong with that
theory and that's very annoying because
it's a really good theory and,
and people have been coming at it from
all sorts of angles and it sort of
matches the phenomenological ideas that
actually matches heidegger's thinking
quite nicely and that it was derived as
far as I can tell virtually
independently of heidegger.
And it goes along well with the
neuroscience of anxiety and motivation
in general.
Like it's a vicious theory.
But here's the problem.
So for a long time people debated about
who the hell was authoritarian,
you know,
because you could say after the Second
World War,
most people assumed that all the damn
authoritarians were on the right way.
Right?
They were the fascists.
And so you could say that's an
exaggeration of conservatism.
Get all that seems kind of reasonable.
But then people pointed out later,
well,
yeah,
but let's not forget about the radical
left wingers because by the time they
become communist dictators,
they seem pretty damn old press of an
intolerant to.
Alright.
So I would say we don't understand what
happens when political systems get too
far in any direction,
but there are models which are in
development that basically indicate that
imagine this is agreeable list and this
is disagreeableness,
okay,
and you can think about them as a
continuum,
but let's not do that.
Let's twist them.
So they form a circle,
all right?
And then we'll say,
well,
how agreeable should you be?
Well,
if you're disagreeable and this
disagreeable things are going pretty
well for you.
It's a nice place to be.
But if you're this agreeable,
well then you turn into Freud's
devouring mother,
right?
You're so damn easy to get along with
it.
It's okay.
You just do everything for your child.
Absolutely everything forever.
And by that doing that,
you undermine their capabilities and
they,
they remain locked in the eatables
situation.
So that's like too much mercy and pity.
Or You could be like the tyrannical
father,
like the crumb brother's father who was
like completely disagreeable and
extraordinarily punitive.
But the thing is it ends up in the same
place.
It,
they both ended up in a variation of
hell.
And so these models seem to seem to
promote the idea that if you run any
virtue too far,
it turns into a vice and all the vices
have more common in each other with each
other than they do with everything else,
with anything else.
So bad things are lumped together more
because they're bad than they are by
what variant of bad they happen to be.
And we kind of know that because if,
you know,
when we developed the big five,
when people develop the big five because
it wasn't me,
they had,
they threw out all the,
uh,
evaluative words.
That was the idea.
They threw out all the evaluative boards
like good and evil disappeared.
So anything that seemed to have a moral
overtone was arbitrarily thrown out.
Now there was actually some statistical
reasons for that.
And the statistical reason is,
is if you just leave the good,
you know,
the,
the adjectives that represent someone as
good or the adjectives that represent
someone as evil.
If you leave those in the damn analysis,
then you get one whopping factor,
which is something like good versus
evil.
And that's not that helpful.
Maybe anyways,
so you throw all those things out so
they don't distort your,
your analysis,
and then that's when you get the five
factors revealing themselves.
So,
but if you throw the pejorative items
back in,
then you get this whopping single
dimension.
Now one of the things you should think
about that,
especially those of you who are going to
be researchers,
is the fact that the evaluative words
were thrown out of the big five
adjective pool before the big five were
derived,
makes the correlation between the big
five factors and psychopathology much
weaker than it would otherwise be.
Right?
Because with psychopathology,
you know,
a lot of it can't be described without
roughly good versus evil.
You know,
it depends on the cycle,
pathological condition,
but if you're describing like
what murderous pedophilia,
you know,
it's hard to use adjectives that aren't
loading pretty hard on the negative end
of the adjective distribution.
You know,
when that's the case with most
personality disorders,
you know,
because there seems to be an element of
misbehavior and many of them.
And so the big five isn't correlated all
that strongly with most measures of say,
personality disorders,
but that's partly because all the words
that weren't correlate were thrown out
before the analysis was done.
And so that's something you really,
really need to know.
Okay,
so
back one step,
because I said
that there's a.
That there's a problem with the theory
that I presented to you.
Here's the problem.
We're going to assume for the time
being,
the easiest place to localize
authoritarianism is on the right hand
end of the spectrum.
Okay,
so we're going to think about fascism.
Roughly.
Speak in.
I think that totalitarian governments
tend towards fascism whether they're
left or right wing,
but how to sort that out hasn't been
established yet.
We don't exactly know what makes left
wing authoritarian is like right wing
authoritarian.
Something does,
but we don't know.
So I'm going to ignore that for a moment
and I'm going to concentrate on the
right wing,
on the right wing side of the spectrum,
the conservative side of the spectrum.
Now we know some things about
conservatives.
They don't like foreigners that much.
They're pretty tradition heavy.
They tend to frown on non normal forms
of sexual interaction or even on many
normal forms of sexual interaction.
They may not even be that happy about
fun,
you know,
so you could say the conservative is
basically trying to destabilize society
so that there isn't a lot that's
unpredictable that's going to go on or
that's going to go on in the future and
so they're trying to maintain stability
and you can give them some credit for
that because it's the match between your
expectations and the way the world lays
itself out that basically inhibit your
stress response.
So stability,
man,
it's something you probably can't
appreciate until you've had it's
complete absence,
you know,
while the liberals,
their,
their position is.
Yeah,
yeah.
Stability.
The problem is stability gets old unless
you keep updating it.
So you know you can't be,
you can't clamp too hard down on change
because if you do then the system gets
stale and outdated and the stability
goes away anyway.
So you go out to allow some change and
some exploration and some growth.
And then the battle is between the
people who wants to ability and the
people who want change and neither of
them is right.
It's the argument.
That's right,
right.
They got to keep arguing about it
because whether we should be more stable
or more plastic,
roughly speaking depends on the context
and the time.
And so that's something to think about
too because a lot of you are going,
most of your left wingers because you're
open,
you're open and that's a very big marker
of the proclivity towards left wing
thinking.
And so you're all going to be thinking
that the left wingers are right,
but,
but it's,
it's a primitive attitude if your
scientific.
Because really what seems to happen is
that both attitudes are right and
they're both adapted to slightly
different evolutionary conditions.
So there are variants of the damn big
five,
those political beliefs.
So liberal people are high in openness
and low in conscientiousness.
Whereas right wing people are low in
openness and high in conscientiousness.
And there's implications to that.
One is liberal start the companies for
example,
but conservatives run them.
So
art artists settled territory and make
real estate values rise.
They're very open people,
but then the conservatives swoop in and
monetize it,
which is kinda hard on artists,
but my point is is that there's a
dynamic between these two positions that
has to be maintained dynamically in
order for the system to survive because
you need to stabilize the damn thing so
it doesn't fall apart,
but you have to keep it adapted to
continual change.
And the only way you can figure out how
much of that should be done on either
side is to keep talking to the people
that you don't like because it's the
only way to figure it out.
So some people pull this way and some
people pull the other way and we hope
that the middle of the polling basically
matches the line of optimal progression.
So that's a much better way of thinking
about democracy.
Okay?
Now,
so back to the problem.
Now
the problem is if you take this damn
model and you think about conservatives,
you're gonna think those people should
be higher in neuroticism.
Like if that,
if their defining characteristic is
inability to tolerate it normally or one
of their defining characteristics,
then you'd think,
well,
they should be more timid.
On average.
They should have more depression,
they should be more anxious,
they should have more negative emotion
in general,
so you'd.
You'd think you'd see some reflection of
that in neuroticism,
but you don't
at all.
In fact,
liberals seemed to be a little more
neurotic than conservatives,
so and in fact the most neurotic people
seem to be male liberals,
so you think,
well,
maybe you could salvage the old theory
because you could say,
well,
the damn conservatives are so protected
by the radiology that they mask their
underlying neuroticism so well that it
actually reverses,
but if you're stupid theory can predict
the reverse of what it should predict,
then it's not a very good theory and so
you couldn't do that,
but you know you're pushing your luck at
that point.
It's better to think,
hm,
something screwy here.
Something's not right.
Even though it's also conservatives
score higher in in wellbeing measures of
wellbeing,
which is basically extroversion,
minus neuroticism,
something like that.
With maybe a bit of conscientiousness
thrown in and they're conscientious
behavior does tend to make their life
turn out more stable across time so
they're less likely conscientious.
People,
for example,
are less likely to get divorced.
So it's hard to reconcile the fact that
those damn conservatives keep insisting
that they're not neurotic with the
theories that predict well they have to
be because the reason they're so rigid,
especially if you've cranked their
beliefs over to the right is because
they're afraid of foreigners,
new ideas and you know,
all the sorts of things that right
wingers are hypothetically afraid of,
but they're not.
And they actually seem to be like,
like I said,
they report that they're happier.
You know,
when you could say,
well,
it's naive,
happiness and all that,
but you can't say those things after you
make the finding.
Right?
Because you're explaining it away.
You have to predict the damn thing.
You can backfill your theory later.
Now,
however,
conservatives are higher than
conscientiousness.
So you're saying,
so what?
What the hell does that have to do with
emotional regulation?
You know,
when you could say,
well,
they make more.
They are there,
their lives are more stable,
so the external manifestations of the
society that they encompass themselves
in are more stable,
so there's not as much normally.
Okay,
that's possible.
However now and that's,
And it may be even,
it's part of it.
About seven years ago,
I did some work with one of my students,
call Indian.
He did a lot of this.
Um,
I had recognized by that time that
the psychometric that the big five
needed to be psychometrically
differentiated or maybe more than it was
because at that point that the stage was
basically,
there were the big five that usually
measured by an instrument called the neo
or the neo pii or the Neil Pei revised.
You've got your five factors and then
each of them were broken down into what
they called facet.
So they were sub sections of the each
trait.
But the problem with the damn facets as
they weren't empirically derived,
you know,
the factors were derived from factor
analysis.
It's just more or less arbitrary
statistics or at least objective
statistics.
But then the facets where like a guess.
And we thought,
well,
you know,
you can't rely on statistical reasoning
to formulate the major part of the
theory.
Then just gas sat the higher resolution
detail,
so calling factor analyzed our data set
called the Ip Ip,
which is the international pool of
that's item pool in international
ip Ip,
I don't remember what it stands for.
A guy named Lou Goldberg put it up
online and he was one of the founders of
the big five theory,
the adjective form of the Big Five
theory,
so Colin factor and analyze that very
carefully and what he found in a
differentiated factor analysis was that
you could take each of the big five and
you could break them weirdly enough into
two.
So each of the big five had to.
So extroversion had enthusiasm and
assertiveness and then neuroticism had
withdrawal and volatility and actually
there's some evidence showing that those
actually have different neurological
underpinnings was quite cool.
Agreeableness factors out into
politeness and compassion and liberals
are higher on compassion.
That's the bleeding heart.
Liberal and Conservatives are higher on
politeness.
If you mangled the two together,
you don't get any difference in
agreeableness between the political
dimensions,
but if you separate them,
then the liberals are compassionate and
the Conservatives are polite and we
think that politeness may be the more
conforming end of agreeableness,
you know,
so.
All right,
Nan,
openness.
This is a good one.
Roughly speaking,
openness seems to fragment into openness
to experience and intellect and openness
to experience predicts whether you're
going to take the humanities versus the
sciences and it's the factor that's most
strongly associated with artistic
creativity and aesthetic sensibility and
philosophy,
philosophical idiation and
entrepreneurial ability because
entrepreneurs load with the bloody
artists,
which is pretty hard on your basic
conservative capitalists,
right?
Because they'd rather.
It wasn't that way,
but it does turn out that that's.
That's how it works out and then
conscientiousness fragments into
industriousness,
which we do not understand at all
really.
We just don't have no idea what that
trait is like.
Why do people work hard towards their
goals?
We can't find a single bloody laboratory
task that industrious people do better
than non industrious people.
Despite the fact that industriousness is
an excellent predictor of longterm life
outcomes,
it's like,
what the hell?
You know,
we can't boil that down to a task in the
lab.
We've had people do things like count
ends,
ams,
and use in many,
many sentences a count the use Jesus.
You'd think that that would be something
that an industrious conservative could
get right into,
you know,
but no,
there's no effect whatsoever.
We can find some things that industrious
and conscientious people do worse.
So we have lab tests where they do
worse.
It's like
that's something but.
But anyways,
it's a great mystery and I've been
trying to crack that for like six years
with no success at all.
We keep getting industrious people to do
things and they seem just as useless as
non industrious people even though we
know that's not true.
It's a very good predictor of academic
grades,
by the way.
Conscientiousness,
and I'm sure it's the industrious
component.
It's just about as powerful as Iq.
Oh yeah.
Openness,
creativity and ICU.
Intellect is roughly icu except the
intellect measure of.
It's kind of bad because if I asked you
how smart you are on a scale from one to
seven,
you'll tell me and that will correlate
with your Iq,
but Iq measures way more accurate than
how smart you think you are.
So that's a.
that's a cool division.
That's very useful division.
Okay,
but on now on the conscientious and
we've got orderliness and industrious
now turns out that the conservatives are
more orderly than the liberals.
Not more industrious.
Now that's now you think,
Ooh,
that's kind of cool because one of the
things you might say about the Germans
for example,
is that they are orderly and you could
certainly say that about Hitler because
he was damn orderly and orderly.
People we know conscientiousness is
associated with anti immigration
attitudes and,
and you know,
a moral stance against non normative
forms of sexual behavior and,
but conscientious people all,
she'll wash their hands more and their
standards of hygiene are better and they
are healthier.
So that's kind of interesting.
You know,
that's,
that's an unsettling lake because
there's these positive things that are
associated with orderliness that,
you know,
are obviously positive.
But then there's these other things that
seem to be associated with stigma or
stigmatism and,
and uh,
what,
uh,
you know,
strong Ingroup,
outgroup divisions and derogation of the
outgroup and all the things that you
might see going extraordinarily
pathologically in something like
genocidal fascism,
for example.
Now,
when I was starting to sort this out,
I was reading Hitler's spontaneous talks
at the dinner table which were recorded
over about a three year period.
And one of the things I came to realize
was that he didn't really see him afraid
of Jews and Gypsies.
He seemed disgusted by them and
contemptuous of them,
which is not the same thing [inaudible]
discussed.
It doesn't load on neuroticism or not
very much.
It loads on orderliness.
And so that was a weird surprise because
we thought all the damn negative
emotions clumped together in
neuroticism.
And that was that and the problem,
but discussed which,
which hadn't been studied very much load
zone orderliness.
So then we thought hot,
we've got the biological basis of half
of conscientiousness.
The biological basis is disgust,
sensitivity.
That hasn't been published yet.
Okay.
So I was thinking about that and then
Hitler washed his hands a lot.
He bathed four times a day and he was
also a real
worshiper of willpower and orderly.
People have strong willpower is one of
the things about anorexic people you
know,
they're often anorexics are kind of
strange because they tend to be like
high achieving women.
Fundamentally.
They're usually smart and they're
usually very,
very dedicated and industrious.
But the other thing is they're orderly.
And so what seems to happen with the.
I told you this before with the
anorexics is the disgust system goes off
the wires and it's too much happens with
obsessive compulsive disorder too,
which is usually classified as an
anxiety disorder but really doesn't seem
to be one.
Maybe it's also an anxiety disorder,
but mostly what people with ocd hate is
to be contaminated.
So I had to know CD client once who she
had lost her husband and her children
and everything and she in the hospital
and she'd actually gone so far as to
build like a pseudo airlock on her house
so that her children and her husband
would have to decontaminate themselves
before they entered the house,
you know,
so.
And that was too much for her marriage
to sustain.
And whenever she was walking down the
hall at the hospital and the guys,
the janitors walked by,
she flattened herself up against the
wall,
you know,
and then she'd run off and wash your
hands.
And if you're really OCD is really out
of control,
you wash your hands until the skin is
raw basically.
Or until you run out of soap,
which you try running out of soap.
When you're using a bar of soap,
you have to wash your hands a lot or you
shower until you run out of hot water.
You can't stop.
And so you're never cleaned enough.
And the,
I was doing exposure therapy with her,
which means you have to sort of make the
person make contact with what they don't
want to make contact with and you do it
step wise,
like you just don't throw them into a
garbage can,
you know,
you have to get them to agree to,
to what degree they're willing to expose
themselves.
And so this is what I could get her to
do if I took a garbage can that was new.
And I took a garbage bag that was new
and I put them over there and I gave her
a pool cue.
She would touch the new garbage can with
the new garbage bag,
with the pool cue.
That was the best she could do.
And even then,
like I was talking to her perfectly
normal appearing person,
you know,
in,
in many respects touch whack.
Like she's,
she's going to that sake and she's going
to wash your hands right now and you're
supposed to do re response prevention,
which is why you don't get to wash your
hands.
And so that turns out to be a very
awkward thing to do in the middle of a
psychiatric ward because I was standing
there in the door trying not to let her
get to the bathroom and she was wanting
to get to the bathroom.
So all the other psychiatric patients
came up and you know,
they started accusing me of basically
being an authoritarian and interfering
with her rights and it's wall.
It's a weird thing,
a,
because,
you know,
was she given me permission five minutes
before when she was in the normal state
of mind and now she was retracting it.
So who the hell did I ever contract
with?
And the answer is her now,
because you can't sell yourself into
slavery roughly speaking,
you don't have that.
Right?
So maybe I was interfering with their
rights,
you know,
it's a tricky thing because
while she was hospitalized,
so obviously something had gone wrong,
but anyways,
you get the picture.
So it gives you an example of how
powerful contamination concern can be.
Okay.
Now then there was a paper published in
Plos one awhile back
looking at the prevalence of infectious
diseases in route in countries around
the world and then in provinces within
countries,
and then they measured the authoritarian
attitudes using an authoritarian
attitudes scale logically enough and
what they found was the higher the
prevalence of infectious diseases in the
geographical locale,
the more authoritarian people were
locally in their individual political
attitudes and the correlation wasn't
point two,
which is the general correlation between
a personality trait and some phenomena.
Point two,
point three,
if you're really lucky,
point five,
if it's ICU with that's the best he ever
get.
It was like point seven.
It's like,
wow,
that's unbelievable.
It's something to do with contamination
and infection transmission,
and so then I was thinking this is
really annoying because this whole
expectation theory,
it's beautiful.
It's.
It works at a neurological level.
It works at neuro psychological level.
You can understand it pharmacologically,
it makes conceptual sense.
You can see that it unites theories that
were derived from all sorts of different
places.
If it has all the classic elements of a
beautiful theory and and it's wrong,
and so then I thought,
all right,
what the hell,
its orderliness and discussed what is
going on there,
and the sticking point was I could
understand
how your brain could calculate how upset
it should get when you hit an anomaly by
referring to this hierarchy.
That took me a long time to figure that
out,
like 10 years probably to map that out
and I thought,
okay,
and then you know how neurotic you are
and how high in esteem you're held by
your,
by your,
the people around you.
That's fine.
But then what does disgust do about
that?
Disgust doesn't seem to undo your damn
belief system.
You know,
like you can encounter something
disgusting and you know,
you,
you may be revolted by it.
It's a very,
very physiological sensation,
right?
Maybe I'll even throw up if it's,
if it's bad enough and maybe you'll be
shocked to the point where you're damn
near traumatized,
you know,
and that's disgust related trauma,
which we don't really understand,
but you're not going to give up your
damn beliefs.
Not Most of the time it doesn't seem to
represent a direct challenge to the
validity of your,
like Islam faith or Islamic faith or
something like that.
So what the hell is going on?
So then I was talking to one of my
graduates,
there's graduate students this morning,
we're trying to sort this out.
And I was thinking,
okay,
what would happen?
Here's an experiment we're thinking
about running.
So you,
you tell me what you think about this.
So
we thought we would take people have a
different range of appearance,
you know,
from really not so beautiful too,
quite attractive and different,
different races and different
ethnicities.
And then we would announce the
ethnicity,
you know,
Jewish Bang,
we'd show them a picture black,
show them a picture Caucasian Bank,
show them a picture and the pictures
would vary in attractiveness.
But then what we're gonna do is we're
going to morph them with snakes and
rats.
So then you,
because you can take a morphing program,
right?
And you could,
I could make you like 10 percent snake
our percent wrapped.
You've seen that movies all the time.
And so then the question would be,
would you be more likely a to see an
unattractive person as a rat or a snake?
And B,
would you be more likely to see a person
who isn't a member of your ethnic and
racial group as a rat or a snake?
Ha.
Now that's interesting because the thing
to do with rats and snakes is get rid of
them.
Right?
And that's a problem.
So,
and then we thought we would also
measure how orderly people were to see
if that mediated,
the degree to which they were willing to
perceive and be in place at perception.
Fundamentally whether this person was
rat or snake.
Like we've got some other experience
experiments that are of the same sort
device.
So I think that's a great experiment.
I'm really curious.
And then we'd have people rate them.
It's like how afraid are you of this
person?
How happy does this person make you
know how,
how,
how contemptuous are you have this
person,
how disgusted are you by this person?
You know,
a whole emotional response scale.
And hopefully what we would find is the
orderly people were more contemptuous
and disgusted but not more afraid by the
morphed faces and they would be more
likely to categorize them as rat and
snake,
like especially if they were from a
different ethnic group or race.
So it's a scary experiment,
but it would allow us to distinguish
between fear and,
and,
and contempt.
And then I was thinking,
well still why do the hell do you care?
Why is the disgusting so important?
What the hell does it have to do with
you?
And then I was remembering maybe,
I don't know,
maybe this game doesn't even exist
anymore because the world has changed,
but I bet it does.
When I was a little kid in like grade
one,
we used to play this game in school and
the game was,
I think on the simpsons they call it
cooties,
but we called it flees.
And so we'd play this recess and some
person would have fleas and then they
would chase you around and they touched
you.
And then you had fleas and everyone ran
away from you.
And the game often start,
sometimes it was just spontaneous,
but often the game could take a vicious
twist and one of the lower status kids
in the room would get,
you know,
accused of having fleas and that just
wouldn't be,
wouldn't be just a game that'd be a
source of taunting and exclusion.
So how many of you can remember games
like that?
Okay.
Okay,
good,
good.
So that shows all this political
correctness hasn't done a goddamn thing
to how children behave,
you know,
and actually that's a relief to me.
So.
Okay,
so then you think what the hell's going
on there?
And the first thing that's going out is
that the kids are playing out the idea
of contamination,
right?
So let's say your contempt dibble and
disgusting,
you know,
so maybe you,
you have syphilis because you're a,
what do you call your,
uh,
your,
your dissolute and they botched and you
know,
it's gone to the final stage and it's
just horrific.
So anybody who is going to look at you
is going to have a reaction like this.
They're,
you know,
they're gonna want to look away.
Okay?
So then I was thinking,
what happens if you touch someone like
that?
No,
no,
no.
Think about it.
Now,
think about it for a minute.
Well,
first of all,
in a place where there's lots of
infectious diseases,
what happens is then you die.
So that's not a good thing you know,
or if you're near anything corrupt like
a carcass that has been rotting,
you don't get to eat it because then you
die like you gotta be sensitive to
discussed because otherwise you'll run
into contamination and the contamination
will kill you.
The question is how contagious is
contamination?
And I think that's the issue.
So now you've put yourself in this
position,
so you're on a dating site and you find
someone,
and this might even be more powerful
initially for women than for men because
I don't know if you know this,
but women rank 85 percent of men as
below average in attractiveness.
Now men get the revenge.
Don't get me wrong,
I'm not trying to make a case that women
are more demanded when it comes to men
than men are.
When it comes to women.
It's just they're demented in different
ways.
So.
So then you think it's interesting
because I've watched my daughter go
through tinder,
you know,
it's sort of painful.
It's like,
nope,
don't,
don't.
Nope.
Nope,
nope.
And you know,
she's,
she's Kinda,
she kinda thinks it's funny and I
suppose it is,
but it's cruel as hell,
right?
If all these poor we easily guys,
they're just getting sorted into the,
you should not be in the damn meeting
pool pile.
Right?
Right.
And that's a fundamental judgment.
You should not be in the meeting pool.
Like if you're off on a genocidal spree,
that's exactly what you're trying to do.
You're trying to prevent that.
So,
you know,
I'm not saying my daughter's got
genocidal tendencies,
although she probably does because she
is human by the way.
So.
Alright.
So now
let's say that you've categorized some
person in there as you know,
you're not going to respond to their
damn email and you know,
you've put them down as a one out of 10,
you know,
so no,
no.
And then someone says you have to go out
with that person.
You have to act.
Ask that person out and then you think,
well,
how are you going to react to that,
that idea?
Well,
the first thing is I think you're going
to be angry at the person who's going to
force you to do that.
It's going to be anger and then the
second thing is how are you going to
feel when you bring that person into
public with you,
around your friends?
Okay,
how are you going to feel?
And the answer to that is
you're going to feel disgusted and
ashamed and the reason for that is
because
it's.
It's,
it's contaminating,
it's catching,
and so then that puts the damn theories
together and this is why
if I forced you to go out with someone
that's low status and will say low
attractiveness,
we'll put the whole package together,
low attractiveness,
low socioeconomic status,
no real hope for the future,
and really unlikable.
We can put all those sorts of things
together and you're going to think no
way,
and then you bring that person out on a
date with all your friends and they
think,
what the hell is up with you?
And so maybe you're an eight,
roughly speaking,
and then you get to go visit five land
for awhile.
Okay,
now what happens to you?
Now?
This is where it gets tricky.
So we know
that you liked the lobster.
Have a counter way down in the bottom of
your brain that's really,
really old.
It's pre-cognitive.
It's even pre emotional.
It's way down there.
Our reticular activating level.
And what it does is scan the world to
figure out where you are in the
hierarchy and it actually matters
because if you're low,
then you die or you're stressed or your
children die.
You know,
and you,
you're,
everything's worrisome to you because
you're barely clinging onto the edge of
existence and you will only take
impulsive pleasures because that's the
longest span that you can count on
having pleasures over and it's rough at
the bottom and you get low status mates
if you get any at all and it's not good.
So you actually do not want to be there.
And there's a reason for that.
Whereas at the cop,
it's like,
yes,
you know,
you get preferential access to
everything,
everything.
So it's better to be there and you can
say what you want about egalitarianism
and there's lots of arguments to be held
on both sides,
but given a choice you will go up rather
than down.
So let's say you associate with someone
who's contaminated and it knocks your
status down.
Now how does it do that?
Well,
it might do it a variety of ways.
You feel bad about yourself.
So that would be low self esteem.
So that means the part of your brain
that's evaluating you as a high status
competent being is now doubtful about
whether you actually fit that
description.
And then there's all your peers because
they're judging you like mad.
And what they're basically doing is
status evaluation.
Are you like a lowly,
a crumb brother who's absolutely outside
the meeting hierarchy completely?
Or are you like Mr Vampire billionaire,
who's the,
you know,
the,
uh,
dawn linen vampire billionaire who's at
the pinnacle of generic female literary
pornography.
So that's basically the,
the hierarchy.
So the problem is is that if you take a
dominance,
hit
your serotonin level,
fall,
what that does is increase your negative
emotion and decrease your positive
emotion and increase the probability
that when anything abnormal is so curves
that you're going to have a generalized
stress response.
So that's the connection between the
damn theories.
If you're associated with the disgusting
your status falls.
And that's what these stabilizes the
belief hierarchy.
It's not a direct effect on belief.
And that puts the problem in a
completely different light in many ways.
It's like,
what?
What the hell are you supposed to do
about that?
Exactly.
Because it looks like
there's no denying the fact that the top
of the bottom or top of the dominant
Turkey's a better place.
Oh,
I got to put one more twist in that.
So you know,
the,
the terror management theories and
they're like basically say that it's
your belief system,
it stabilizes your emotions.
And then you know,
I vary that a bit and said,
well,
wait a minute.
It's your expectation,
desire,
hierarchy and the match between that in
the world that stabilizes your emotions.
And that's partly because it does,
because you're not freezing to death or
overheated or starving,
but also because you can sit in a room
like this with all the other conformance
to feel like no one's going to,
you know,
stand up screaming and become murderous,
which is a really good thing.
So,
but here's a twist.
The twist would be the degree to which
the expectancy desire map regulates your
emotions and your general response.
Your general stress response is
proportionate to your position in the
dominance hierarchy,
right?
So it's more dilated by the degree of
success that you have and that's an
important sale because it means the,
the integrity of your theory about the
world works better as well as that
theory of the world is in fact working
well for you,
which means you're near the top of the
dominance hierarchy.
And then it really regulates your
emotions as it should because the
environment is less dangerous for you.
It's not psychological man.
If you're hiring the dominance
hierarchy,
even in Canada and you have someone
who's sick in your family,
they get to see the doctor a lot,
long time before someone who has a low
Iq and no social connections and it's
not just corruption,
you know,
there's an element of that who,
it's just successful conscientious
people who are open.
They have access to all sorts of
strategies and plans and ways of
figuring out,
figuring things out that people who are
at the bottom of the dominant Turkey,
they just can't even muster.
Plus they're way more likely to be taken
seriously when they go see a doctor
because they're articulate,
you know,
so it's a big deal.
Okay,
so then we're saying the degree to which
your theory protects you from the world
and your theory and its incarnation in
the actual world is proportional to
where you are in the dominance
hierarchy.
And so what that means is that if you
ever associate with anything or anyone
that lowers your status,
you forfeit the protection of the
associate cultural confines.
And the best way to do that is to
associate yourself with someone who is
disgusting or contemptible.
Now the next problem.
So I think I was thrilled about that
this morning.
I tell you,
because I've been trying to figure this
out for like six years.
I was thinking,
how the hell do these things tied
together?
And I think,
I don't think that's absolutely right,
but I think it's,
it's pushing towards something that's
right.
But then the problem that comes out of
that is what do you do about it?
You know,
it's one,
it's a real bind,
isn't it?
Because you're just not going to get rid
of the damn hierarchies.
It's not even clear that you should,
partly because you know,
you can be cynical like a postmodernist
and you can say,
well hierarchies are just based on
power,
which is,
that's such a stupid theory that it's
just painful.
Some hierarchies are based on power,
but lot of them are based on competence,
right?
In a functioning society it's like,
who do you want to do your brain
surgery?
You know,
do you want to have the person who
really knows how to do brain surgery or
do you want some person who's just,
you know,
sort of they're doing it as an amateur
in,
in the back alley,
you know,
so you're going to assume that there's a
bloody hierarchy and that it's based on
competence and that you're going to peel
from the top and so they're going to be
more powerful obviously because they're
at the top of the hierarchy.
But you're going to be pretty damn
thrilled about that when you're looking
for competence,
which you often are.
And to think about all that is power.
It's like,
you know,
really like live in the world.
Some of its power,
but lots of it isn't so.
So if it's our proclivity to arrange
ourselves in dominance hierarchies and
our dislike of our associated anything
that looks contaminated in a disgusting
sort of way,
and the reason that,
that,
that'll lower are visible status in her
own eyes and in the eyes of other
people.
How the hell do you get people to be
tolerant?
You know?
And the thing is,
you're not tolerant and for all the talk
about egalitarianism,
I can tell you the egalitarian thing to
do is to date the next person who asks
you and you're not going to do that and
no bloody wonder.
So that's a big.
And you can talk around that all you
want,
but you know,
we know if you're going to be a
biologist about this sort of thing,
which is useful.
I don't think you should only view
people through biological lenses because
our biological lenses aren't very
sophisticated,
but you know it's pretty damn hard to
argue with the idea that you're
concerned roughly speaking with two
things and one is or not you survive.
And the other is whether or not your
progeny survive and thrive.
You know when you can just boil that
down to the desire to have healthy,
competent,
beautiful,
attractive,
successful children.
It's like,
is that a vice or a virtue?
Well,
if you can't make that egalitarianism,
like good luck with the rest of it.
It's like smoke and mirrors.
As far as I can tell,
you might be able to alleviate suffering
at the bottom of the dominance
hierarchy,
although even that's much more difficult
than you think because you know,
if you pump resources from the top to
the bottom,
what happens is the resources fly right
up to the top again,
you know,
it's almost,
it's like it's like pumping water up
hill.
It's bad analogy because it's backwards,
but you're fighting against a very,
very powerful tendency for resources to
aggregate themselves into single
locations.
And I'll talk to you a lot about that
when we get to intelligence because it's
a,
it's like a bloody natural law.
It's really hard to fight against it.
And it's like that inequality is
characteristic of all societies.
Even egalitarian societies.
It's really hard to get rid of it and
you're not going to get rid of it in the
sexual world.
That's for sure.
So you know,
I thought about,
and we've talked a lot about in this
class,
in the sections on phenomenology and
existentialism and you know,
this idea that there's something
redemptive about living in truth,
you know,
and that that seems to protect people
against the worst elements of rigid and
judgmental dominance hierarchies.
And I think I think discussed can even
get more out of hand when you get
arrogant and superior,
you know,
and you're looking down on the
contemptible from a High Place of
narcissism.
And so maybe part of living in truth
helps you not fall prey to that.
What narcissistic,
judgmental tendency,
and that'll keep some of this under
control,
but how to deal with the underlying
problem of,
of disgust,
sensitivity.
What are you going to be?
Not Orderly.
That's not helpful.
You know,
now you know,
one thing that you might think about is
that compassion,
which is part of agreeableness might
moderate the judgmental tendency of
orderliness.
They're not opposites,
right?
Because they're on different dimensions
and that's kind of one of the liberal
ideas.
Even though liberals are mostly high in
openness and low in orderliness,
they're also higher in compassion than
conservatives.
Conservatives,
liberals debate a lot about the role of
compassion because the Conservatives
think you're just being a new mother,
you know,
and the Liberals think,
well,
you're just being a totalitarian father
and both of those things can and are
true,
but it seems to me that there's
something about compassion that that
might serve at least to some degree as
an antidote for the pathological
elements of orderliness,
which include,
by the way,
conservatives,
especially the ordinary ones are also
much more judgemental.
So if you present to them someone who's
committed a moral crime,
like careless prostitution,
say they will and you ask them how long
that person should be in prison,
then the orderly person will say that
they should be in prison longer than the
person who's disorderly.
And
so then I guess the question is can
compassion mediate that without it
falling into like the hellish Friday
Anita Pool pit
now?
Anyways,
that's about as far as I've got with
that.
So.
So I thought I'd tell you that because I
think it's worth knowing and because I
was too excited about it.
Not too so.
So we'll see you on Thursday.